i bought a 2012 macbook air for only a
hundred eighty dollars and it really
surprised me now this thing is a macbook
air and believe it or not it comes with
eight gigs of ram and 250 gigabytes of
ssd
which is what the brand new m2 macbook
airs come with 10 years later and after
having it for about a week i want to
share my experience using it with you
guys both the positives and things that
surprised me as well as the negatives
and who should not buy it and then who
should buy it and i should be very happy
with it it'll be better than other brand
new options at low price points now the
first thing that really stands out is
that massive bezel with these new macs
coming out that have this super thin
even sides on the screen well this thing
like blinds you with that silver bezel
now after using it for a bit it does
tend to kind of disappear not completely
because it's huge but you start to
ignore it a bit and it's not too bad
now as far as the overall design it
doesn't look that old because the wet
shape was around until well i guess it's
still around with the m1 macbook air
that's still being sold the next thing
was max safe this thing had it way back
then apple got rid of it thankfully they
brought it back and the connector is
very similar has that light on top now
the cable is not as nice as the new ones
it's not braided and it is built into
the power brick so it's not removable
but one thing we don't have in 2022 are
these cool little clips that opened up i
use these all the time back in the day
and it makes it very convenient to wrap
up your cable and keep it tidy and
another thing that i now miss is that
iconic glowing apple logo it would be
great if they could bring it back
there's just something cool about it
when it turns on it really pops out and
it doesn't smudge like the new silver
ones now what about usability day-to-day
well this thing has two usb ports and
they are usb 3.0 which surprised me as
well so they aren't slow and then we
also have an sd card reader which is
handy to have there's no reason why we
couldn't have had that in the new m2
macbook air along with that we have that
magsafe charger and we have a
thunderbolt port which can actually
daisy chain two displays together which
we also don't have now i used to own a
2015 version of this and i definitely
enjoyed it i used it mostly for web
browsing a little bit of video editing
and doing the same thing with this one
from 2012 actually did quite a good job
websites loaded up surprisingly quickly
and because it has eight gigabytes of
ram i didn't really notice any sort of
slowdowns for that simple kind of use
now i know a lot of you guys mentioned
that the mt macbook air with this stock
256gb ssd people won't notice the
performance difference because they're
just web browsing well with this thing
it also web browsers just fine so if
you're somebody that is just using email
maybe watching some youtube videos
things like that do you really need to
spend that extra money now of course
nobody's gonna stop you if you have it
but you don't need to
this thing handles all those basic tasks
without any issues for those of you guys
that type a lot it also does a pretty
good job we have the old school keyboard
that so many people loved and wanted
back once apple released the butterfly
keys
they're not as good as the new ones the
keys are a little bit on the smaller
side so it took me a bit to get used to
that but overall they do feel good for
typing now let's go to some downsides
the trackpad has frustrated me if you're
somebody that is used to apple's new
force touch track pads going back to a
diving board design it just sucks you
have to press more towards the bottom
and then if you're off a bit you can
have some issues with right clicking or
you're pressing at the top and it's not
registering because you have to click
way harder now of course you can get
used to that but that's something that
still stuck with me here even a week
later and the same thing goes for the
speakers there's huge modules in it
these big huge enclosures so you think
it would sound good but when we compared
it with the new macbook air well just
take a listen for yourself
[Music]
[Music]
the webcam is also a potato in 2022
terms this might have been the biggest
thing that kind of surprised me because
it is a 720p webcam but the processing
was just terrible back then so i would
probably say you'd want to use something
external if you're going to be doing
that now with that this thing can only
update to mac os catalina so you're not
going to be able to use you know some of
the new features that are released on
the new operating systems you're not
going to get some security updates so
you definitely have to keep that in mind
and before i have to get into
performance and what changing the
thermal paste did
let's talk about this display
it almost hurt my eyes when i first
looked at it just because all the pixels
popped out like crazy and it's really
interesting how our eyes get adjusted to
new displays it becomes a new normal and
displays that didn't look that bad
before they really look bad when you
start looking at them again now if
you're just using this and no other mac
you'll kind of get used to it not
completely because the colors aren't
great but it definitely was the worst
thing about these macbooks not in 2012
when this one launched but at least up
until 2017 which was the last one of
this design with that said this thing
was a hundred and eighty dollars now if
we would look that a year or two ago it
didn't double the price maybe more but
because of apple silicon these old ones
really dropped in value which is great
if you want to pick one up maybe for
yourself a parent that you want using
mac os instead of windows they don't get
any viruses maybe a kid we had multiple
people comment that their kids stopped
using their chromebooks that they got
for free from school because their old
macbook was a lot better overall now
here in 2022 there are new chromebooks
but if you're looking at that price
point of about 180 bucks you will get
one of these which is an 11 inch
chromebook that is very well rated and
actually used to cost 280 bucks it is on
sale now what does that offer you well
you get 4 gigs of ram you get 64
gigabytes of that super slow ssd storage
and the screen is no better likely worse
in terms of contrast than this macbook
air so that puts it into perspective and
i'll show you the performance as well
here in a second now the first thing
that i noticed when i started using it
was the fan
even installing different applications
the fan would spin up and it would get
loud and then when i was looking at
temperatures those were also getting
quite hot just doing simple tasks now
this was a bit annoying it was a little
bit frustrating a little bit funny after
using fanless macbook airs now as we
went through we did some performance
tests i was thinking well what about the
fans there's could be uh you know dust
in there the thermal pace has been in
there for 10 years i don't know if the
refurbishing company does any of that
and so after doing that i decided to go
ahead pop it open and replace the
thermal paste which literally cost about
10 bucks and it's not hard to do at all
i'll go ahead and link some thermal
paste and my little tool kit down in the
video description so what did that do
well the difference was way more than i
expected first off the fans stopped
spinning up when i was using regular
tasks it stayed quiet which was awesome
but then under load instead of hitting
100 506 degrees when running cinebench
or working with photos it literally
maxed out at 92 degrees celsius when we
were doing the cinebench
render which is a massive difference
that's cooler than the new macbooks run
and with that we got about a 10
improvement in score as well now as far
as the graphics this is where this thing
gets slow this is the biggest limitation
with it but those improved by about 23
after switching out the thermal pace
people used to spend hundreds of dollars
to get a cpu upgrade to be able to get
you know 10 15 20 of an improvement so
if you buy one of these definitely make
sure that you swap it out not only for
the performance gains but for the fan
noise as well now our geekbench score
didn't get that much better because that
does short bursts and it doesn't heat up
your system very much
but with that let's compare it to the
chromebook that you would buy for the
same price as far as single core score
this 2012 machine more than doubles it
and it also beats it out in multi-core
sport even though that chromebook has an
eight core processor of course it also
has double the ram and four times the
ssd
that is way faster than what is in that
chromebook so realistically if you can
grab one of these for this price now
there is no reason to buy that
chromebook and with that you can upgrade
the ssd in this thing up to two
terabytes for about 200 bucks or one
terabyte for about a hundred you get the
proper
ssd you can pop in so that's another
factor if you want to
uh you know get some more storage or
just buy an sd that will pop in and give
you more storage since this thing does
have that sd card slot now as far as
battery life this thing only had about
80 cycles on the battery that means that
the battery was swapped out before which
is great and i think the refurbisher
they will swap them out if they're
really bad
or if you get one used you can swap it
out yourself for not a lot of money at
all i'll link a replacement kit as well
and you can expect roughly six or so
hours with this machine now it might be
a little bit worse than a chromebook or
maybe not but that is definitely better
than a 300 windows laptop that you would
buy today so should you buy a 180
2012 macbook air in 2022
well i guess it depends on how much
money you have to spend or who you're
buying it for for a kid or a parent you
can buy one of these not have to worry
about a bunch of windows viruses or
about them breaking expensive machine
and it will do the job great for web
browsing google docs um things like that
they're gonna have a great time or if
you don't have a lot of money to buy say
an 850 m1 macbook air and you need
something there's still a lot of people
using these machines
and they do the job even for a little
bit of light 1080p video editing and
final cut it can actually do that now
you don't want to do 4k that destroys
this machine because its biggest
weakness are graphics and then with that
if you're somebody's going to listen to
a lot of different things with the
built-in speakers of course you can use
headphones or do zoom calls that is more
of a limitation but overall
what else can you buy for this price
point that matches it up really nothing
and this really shows a testament to
apple and how long their machines last
and then with that why in the world are
we still getting eight gig 256 in 2022
but that's for another video so there
you guys go let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below check
out one of those great videos right over
there click above to subscribe this one
max and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you